okay I guess I'm contractually obligated
to make a video explaining my thoughts
about this so here we go
generic footage breakdown video activate
[Music]
spider-man prom trailer dropped way back
in December and I haven't been this
excited for a late-night talk show since
that Deadpool trailer appeared on Conan
well I'm just recycling jokes from my
Twitter now that's a new low anyway it's
been a few months and I've taken time to
sort out my feelings on everything
people usually do these kinds of videos
when the trailer just came out and
they're so riled up about it that they
say everything is universally awesome
about it or universally awful about it
so I want to try something different and
give it a once-over once I've had some
time to think and be fair about it it
was better than I expected you know what
while the real nerves out there come
through every second of footage and
point out how every individual frame
somehow spoils the whole movie while
simultaneously referencing issues 45 93
4 68 and 592 I'm just going to talk
about what stood out most to me and how
I think this is all going to play out
I've been kind of unsure about this
movie since it was announced because
I've been hurt in the past now I've
become paranoid and bitter and afraid to
love again the thing that concerns me
most right now is that it has six
credited writers and we know what
happens when there's too many cooks in
the kitchen non-fan so let's pray that
the script doesn't come out sounding
like it was written by six different
people because that could be very very
bad
now the cast consists of a lot of people
you've never heard of and some that
you've probably heard of Tom Holland is
my favorite spider-man actor so far and
that's coming from someone whose first
experience in a movie theater as a kid
was with the toaster the trailer shows
him pulling off the shy nerd and the
wisecracking hero half of the character
pretty well I've talked about the
importance of this dichotomy before and
he's not wandering around with
fingerless gloves skinny jeans and a
skateboard that's great they got the
casting right however one thing I'm
noticing is that there's a lot of ideas
being used from the ultimate comic like
the scene where he knocks around the
subs wearing the ironic superhero mask
seem to them trying to prove his worth
the condescending Avengers and of course
Yankee mm II met leaps he straight-up
stole a Miles Morales eyed character and
renamed him after a random Peter Parker
side character
he's the goofy friend that spider-man
shares a secret with and confides in
when the go
one gets rough in the superhero biz
Steven got the spilled Legos I have that
death star by the way it took me like
three weeks to build it I can't believe
you just dropped it like that and what
if they needed to do another take for
the scene did they have to rebuild it or
did they just have multiple pre-built
Lego Death Star's from the prop
department ready to go so he can
advocare's whatever I guess that's just
a hint that miles won't be getting a
live action movie anytime soon since one
of his most important characters was
given to Peter instead well sorry
entire half of the fanbase keep holding
out hope though at least you got that
animated movie getting Michael Keaton
for this was a great choice but I'm
really disappointed to find out that
he's playing the vulture yeah it's
probably going to be the best Marvel
villain in a while because Spidey has
the most well-developed one but when
Michael team have made an amazing Norman
Osborn just look at him the corporate
businessman thing he was doing in
Robocop would have been great for Norman
and some of that Beetlejuice charm would
have been great while in a green and
purple suit of armor I feel like I want
to see Norman Osborn's be done right
again because he's a character with a
ton of mileage and can be just as long
reaching and interesting as Loki hell
they play their cards right he could be
the villain and upcoming Avengers movie
you know when he builds his team a bad
guy knock-offs
vultures not a bad character but he's
not worth seeing in multiple movies
I think someone with as much talent as
Michael Keaton is kind of wasted for a
villain who's most likely going to
explode at the end of this movie in a
way that's his own fault like one of his
wings malfunctions and goes boom or I'll
get sucked into the turbine of a plane
or something in an over-the-top battle
on the sky come back here on July 7th
and tell me how close I got that
prediction one thing I know for sure
though is that the only good MGMT songs
are the ones with a loud electronic
chirping noises plus there's also the
fact that shocker somehow factors in all
this but that's confusing a lot of
people are walking around using this
gauntlet clapping one scene they use it
to break into these ATM and another
scene someone uses it to smack
spider-man with a blood the guy we all
originally thought with shocker has one
attached to his wrist
International trailer but so does this
guy in the American trailer and he also
has the weird yellow quilt pattern on
his clothes so which one is the shocker
why do they each have a gauntlet on
opposite hands did they realize they
both wanted to be Shocker and just
decided to share what's this laser thing
that vulture has that's also a
vibrational shock gauntlet things are
these guys working for vultures I don't
know I guess that's the point of a movie
trailer these days it shows us confusing
and conflicting images and we go to the
theater to watch the dialogue that
connects all these action scenes which
they'll release online without context a
month prior is that a cynical way to
look at movies yes it is is it accurate
yes
oh I'm sure a lot of people have already
pointed out that Donald Glover is off to
the side here next to a villain man I
guess he's not playing miles even though
one makes sense because he's 33
well sorry entire half of the fanbase
keep holding out hope though at least
you got that animated movie man if miles
is having this hard of a time just
imagine what it's going to be like to
get the spider-man 2099 live-action
movie off the ground but I digress we
saw a lot of people from the cast list
and very few of them have names at the
moment we know that this is Liz Allen
but who are these people is that Glenn
IMDB says she's Betty Brant for some
reason is that Mary James she says she's
not Mary Jane but he said he wasn't Kahn
so actors are known to be huge liars
there were also those set photos from a
few months ago where he was swinging
around with some mysterious young
redheaded girl who had a camera and in
the ultimate universe MJ had a whole
thing about being an amateur reporter so
she filmed a lot of [ __ ] is that Mary
Jane Doe find out next time on angular
scarab beetle man homecoming I guess
we'll just have to wait and find out
that's the theme of this trailer
questions without answers and that's a
good thing it's got me curious and it's
more than most movie trailers can do
lately gee I wonder what the backstory
of this mummy is I guess the to
homecoming trailers give us a glimpse of
the stuff they for sure got right and
then kind of teases all the
we're still concerned about overall it
didn't give a bad impression and I can't
wait to see more so good job Marvel and
or Sony I don't know who to thank if it
turns out great but I sure know who to
blame if it goes wrong
ah you can't escape me I'll chase you to
the ends of the earth